pour apporter la contradiction elisabeth
laisser paco rabanne j'accueille
philippe zarka du cnrs et alain
gillot-pétré
alors fait pas plaisir
mais il va lui il va bien falloir
d'avenir ils veulent pas s'arrêter au
chai de la 206 dit je veux bien que
monsieur gillot pétré n'a aucune
compétence il va sortir le côté vraiment
ça ça va être monstrueux
non pas une autre langue que j'aime
beaucoup pas je le vois halal par
exemple au brésil présente la météo il
est super ouais et c'est un homme mais
lorsqu'il parle de ces déçus de ce
phénomène là il est trop rigoriste on
sait qu'on est assez bête pour nous on
est là pour isner ce que je sais
exactement ce qu'il va dire alors elle
m'a dit à moi parce que là c'est alors
qu'elle fait demain dimanche
je le paie très bon soir je sais que
t'es bizarre car on sait qu'on annule
alors maintenant que tu as une ancienne
intervalle de vous dire que ça pour être
incendié le doubs n'est pas la météo
dans trois jours de chômage ac ce soir
était la même chose bon écoute et on va
voir en tous les cas donc j accueille
philippe zarka bon soir vous êtes un
honnête homme vous êtes changé
vous êtes chargé de vous êtes chargé de
recherche au cnrs oui au département de
la recherche spatiale un absent temps de
paris à l'observatoire de paris et alain
gillot-pétré évidemment on le présente
plus puisqu'il devrait parler ce présent
tous les cas je ne comprends pas dans
votre exposé là dans cette confrontation
c'est que vous vous assimilez mais direz
vont travailler ma démarche
professionnelle à celle de paco que
j'aime beaucoup à la vue du match à lui
tout seul j'ai apporté la contradiction
qui n'a pas marché attendait les deux
prologues maintenant c'est
elizabeth teissier tous d'accord là bas
j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans l'attende
et j'ai dit tout à l'heure que paco
rabanne avait des flashs comme celui qui
vous a raconté jeu sur les gens qui
jette dans la seine et que vous nous
avez appelé vous interprétiez et oui al
culié à partir des astres oui donc j'ai
bien fait différent c'est une autre
façon de travailler donc voilà
maintenant quand j la contradiction
parce qu'ils se trouvent et qui manque à
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord avec
vous alors justement je me tourne vers
vous pour commencer philippe zarka
est-ce que alors oui enfin bon on va
commencer par cas pourquoi géométriques
et son stade je rentre ici je me fais
agresser north
agressive je suis pas varie pas dit un
mot que je me fais déjà insultés j'étais
avec vous sur un plateau c'est pour cela
je suis passé les souvenirs d'un
monsieur paco rabanne oui je me souviens
pas d'avoir monsieur paco rabanne moi je
n'ai absolument rien contre vous ni ce
que vous prétendez pourquoi parce que
vous faites de la divination vous avez
parfaitement le droit monsieur d'avoir
des flashs moi aussi il m'est arrivé
d'avoir des flashs ce sont des
production d'hormones dans le cerveau
qui font qu'à un moment donné on vend
quelque chose c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait rationnel c'est pas la peine
de faire ça madame
et je vais tenter dans les jours à venir
quand même monsieur attendez vous
ennuyer je vous demande pardon d'aurier
excusé de la façon va vous l'avait
accueilli oui j'ai fait je vous savez
je vous remercie monsieur de votre unité
doit la production est en fait voilà je
vous ai écouté je me suis dit voilà un
monsieur charmant qui est qui a détruit
de divination on verra bien on verra
bien ce qui va se passer mais vous ne
deviez vous dirai largement traduire ce
que vous je vous demande humblement
pardon de vous avoir agressé un si c'est
simplement d'un mauvais souvenirs dans
l'ancien plateau vous avez été très
violent et que vous avez dit de tous les
phénomènes de voyance foutaise et ça ça
m'avait vraiment à l'époque un peu
choqué bien que les drogues et la madame
quant à me contacter ou les abc je n'ai
rien contre vous d'abord je vous trouve
on trouve ou non plus je vous trouve
très belle
encore très brillant mais la nouveauté
de mails vous êtes une star c'est vrai
vous êtes une star des femmes et les
droits en tant que personne à mon
profond respect très petit mais
maintenant cela dit je suis contre
l'astrologie avait le droit j'ai
maintenant le droit tout alors si je dis
quelque chose soyez gentils ne malgré
ses pas dès que je dis un mot en faisant
en toc toc comme vous avez fait tout à
l'heure mais attendez je veux bien me
faire insulter mais au moins fait d'eux
oralement avec des arcs voulait
présenter mes excuses très bien sa copie
mais qui présentait donc j'ai pas bomber
teachers je vous ai vu faire tête quatre
mots à sibiti mais c'est parce que parce
que c'est une vision tellement
matérialiste qui rappelle le 19e siècle
qui rappelle qu'on dia quand il disait
que c'est le cerveau produit sécrète la
pensée me comprenez on a dépassé ça
depuis très longtemps a eu droit d'aller
à toutankhamon et lui du 19e siècle à
brooklyn ce match alors maintenant gérer
pour dépasser sa merde enfin on a
dépassé ça mais on n'a rien proposé de
mieux que je sache philippe arca donc
vous êtes au courant de la faire
il a vraiment l'accès de nos
scientifiques
des joueurs de boules se frotte
les mains
illzach cas sur le plan alors vous vous
êtes donc comme je les dis chargé de
recherche au cnrs est ce que est ce que
par exemple pour reprendre ce que dit
paco rabanne est ce que les
interférences magnétiques qui vont se
produire lors de l'éclipsé est ce que ça
peut déclencher des choses concernant
par exemple à la station orbitale mir
qui nous tomberait dessus alors damman
il ya une chose à dire c'est que
effectivement je suis d'accord avec
alain gillot-pétré c'est j'ai beaucoup
moins de choses à dire par rapport à ce
que dit paco rabanne qui est voyant donc
c'est un peu de la magie donc la science
a pas grand chose à dire dessus j'ai
plus à dire par rapport à ce que
d'elisabeth tessier puisque elles se
fondent et elle prétend que l'astrologie
c'est des prévisions et a causé des
pratiques si le recul j'ai quand même le
culot mon taf a lieu de prétendre dans
les shows j'arrive
j'aurais mis trois marques volent et non
pas du tout mais moi j'ai absolument
rien contre vous personnellement alors
donc bon j'ai j'ai rien à dire sur la
croyance en tant que tel par contre on
peut relever bon peut-être à l'aide de
l'information scientifique toutes les
incohérences les contre-vérités qui a
dans le livre de paco rabanne comme dans
celui de d'elisabeth tessier alors dans
leur dans l'astrologie en plus si l
amalgame avec la science donc il n'est
pas dans le cas de la chorale alors ça
sert donc scientifique maintenant il ya
aussi en tant que citoyen simplement
enfin entendre que personne moi là
vraiment je m'oppose au contenu de ces
deux livres parce que je trouve qu'on
pourra développer mais en gros que les
deux personnes qui écrivent prennent les
gens pour des crétins
et ça ça me gêne senti ça c'est tout non
j'aime ça traîne les gens pour les
crises a dit qu'on était zen alors
suivant 02 travaillé pour celle ci moi
je respecte les gens parce que je les
apporte j'aime les gens de 2,2 de cette
humanité et c'est pour prévenir d'un
danger possible je veux pas me lancer
pour des cons mais vous êtes peut-être
sincère
alors il n'avait pas besoin de ça pour
ça pour être monsieur marcel gagnon
beaucoup de ces salopards l'eau comme je
parle là je détruis ma réputation je
pense que l'on se tape sur les cuisses
trouve là une première question et n'a
rien à voir avec la science des deux
mois puisque vous commencez à dire que
vous avez beaucoup hésité pour y refaire
d'autres et c'est pourquoi vous avez pu
vous n'êtes pas un économiquement
faibles pourquoi vous êtes et ce que
vous avez pas vous avez fait un livre à
100 francs pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
pas fait des campagnes d'affichage aux
normes militaires des choses comme ça à
paarl par les armes on médite je suis en
contrat avec lui alors les uns et les
autres possibilités ce que je fais une
information ce que je fais de mon fric
ne vous intéresse pas vraiment vous dire
qu'il aurait venir les gens je suis au
rouge dans mon compte en banque ou à
téléphoner non mais j'ai pas vos deux
besoin de vous dire ça et je ne possède
rien ni château ni maison ni appartement
à paris il manquera ma propre affaire
qui m'appartient pas ni de voiture je
conduis pas amassé une résidence
simplement je fais minable de leurs
ayants
droits vous savez vous êtes scientifique
je n'ai aucun respect pour vous parce
que quand est ce qu a sagement vitré que
le nuage deux de ceux de tchernobyl
s'arrête à la frontière française parce
qu'il n'avait pas de visa alors je me
tape sur les cuisses je dis qu'est-ce
que cette science tu sais pas que un
courant d'air peter braid franchement
mais vous ne pouvez pas assimiler ce que
dit une personne l'opposition sétif de
l'époque en eau scientifique en général
au pouvoir soit avec eux d'abord
environnement mac os en jeu murray lui
qui a dit ça en plus convoité le dieu de
la une volonté politique derrière un
vrai style yang ne ne plie pas la tête
devant la police de colis dans celui là
c'est moi de vous dire juste de vous
dire un truc parce qu'elle est toute la
carrière vous avez derrière vous tout
s'est tous ces costumes tous les parfums
tout ce qui existe sous l'étiquette sous
le nom de paco rabanne que vos comptes
en banque soit en rouge croyez moi vous
n'êtes pas prévoyant je suis pas fourmis
fait celui-ci galles c'est c'est vrai
que paco van 3000 tonnes enfin sous
votre marque vante 3000 tonnes de
cosmétiques par an alors alors philippe
starck a expliqué maintenant dites nous
pourquoi ces c'est possible pas possible
moi j'aimerai savoir le la station mir
là sont de ligue 1 qu'est ce qui va se
passer il ya 15 jours est tombé à soyouz
en argentine oui effectivement alors ce
que ce que tu as corps habana 10 en fait
n'est pas du tout impossible dans le
sens la probabilité n'est pas zéro
simplement que ça se produise et en plus
ce que ça se produise au lieu et à la
date et à l'heure où il a dit ça les
chances sont extrêmement faibles je sais
pas si on peut les calculer mais c'est
peut-être une sur un million sur un
milliard cirque c'est certainement moins
de chance que de se faire écraser en
sortant dans la rue et pour arriver
alors bon donc je ne dis pas que c'est
impossible entre les chances
scientifique à une prédiction ça n'a
rien à voir non plus est ce qui fait
qu'il ya une chance sur un message sur
mon avis qui dit qu'est-ce qu'il dit là
je veux dire j'ai
franchement on se doute bien que ce
qu'ils disent et puisque c'est une
prédiction ils se basent pas sur des
canons mais il ce qui se fonde sur une
vision et ça c'est le côté voyance
ensuite il a été ensuite il a été
interprété sa vision alors notamment il
a été interprété avec la cad les 4 1 de
nostradamus or comme l'a dit fort
justement il avait de tessier jae-in les
c4 1 sont très obscur et 1 942 mais leur
patience et arbitraire cher monsieur
parce que vous les théories de
scientifiques que vous allez lire
aujourd'hui demain votre totalement
comprendre un nombre comprend vite
contredite parce que moi je suis juste
un maafir était justement la fierté les
scientifiques notent de ne pas énoncer
des routes dites mais nous les vieux
débats des dom et des ferries t qui
permettent d'être dans mon lit car
geneviève j'espère me tromper c'est une
éventualité
le mot éventualité d oui ou non bon
alors ça c'est la meilleure adresse que
philippe starck on va expliquer parce
qu'on en vienne vient pas du jeu là je
vais essayer d'être rapide voilà leur
effectivement d'abord paco rabanne dit
si j'ai tort c'est que j'aurais eu
raison en fait ces contrats saas qu'eux
mêmes et c'est que en gros grâce à ce
que j'ai dit d'accord avc le parler de
mon café au mélies d'accord dame a
décidé chez syfy compter les autres
énormément parce qu'il dit il s'est
ensuite jeu jésuitique il va dire ça il
fera ça je déteste qu'on puisse tout ça
moi dans mon bouquin jeudi c'est une
éventualité si ça n'arrive pas je ferme
ma gueule à jamais voilà c'est parce
qu'un seul aura prier ou etc ça continue
on un
pur et dur alors voilà c'est parce que
j'ai prévenu
e stop c'est vous qui parlait après mois
la répandrais allez-y d'abord il faut
savoir que c'est très peu alors la
station mir fait un tour de la terre en
une heure et demie en gros oui si elle
descend régulièrement à cause de la
friction de la toussaint tétouan elle
descend régulièrement à cause de
l'atmosphère et donc on la repousse
régulièrement pour la remontée alors
évidemment ça coûte de l'argent la
russie a des problèmes ça tout le monde
le sait donc il ya des problèmes la
terre tourne en dessous donc la vraie
politique ça tombe exactement un endroit
un un point donné jeudi est très très
faible alors maintenant si ça tombait 6
supposons que ça tangue qu'est-ce qui se
passerait alors j'ai fait un petit
calcul pour m'amuser on connaît la masse
de la station mir ses 120 tonnes 140 on
connaît sa vitesse aussi si ça tombe ça
fait à peu près 10 puissance 2 joules
bon c'est une seule unité d'énergie
c'est de l'ordre de la dizaine de fois
la bombe d'hiroshima ouais sans les
radiations ainsi que si elle tombe c'est
juste que c'est juste le souffle
d'accord donc avec ça on détruit pas
paris on réalise pas ce qui est dans le
premier chapitre de votre livre avec
saint méen du dioxyde de plutonium à
l'intérieur ça c'est la deuxième chez
sas et deuxième chose permis s'il est
apte à petit a personnellement comme le
personnel au très violent être un petit
rôle celui de tout bon mais encore une
fois hier
c'est tout bon j'habite ici je reviens
ils sont devenus fous
visible continuer alors maintenant le
problème c'est qu est ce que ça contient
alors moi personnellement j'en sais rien
exactement qui est qui et une pile avec
du dioxyde de plutonium dedans comme il
y en a dans la plupart des sondes
spatiales qui ont été lancés c'est
possible c'est une ce n'est néanmoins
pas sûr parce que on met des piles au
dioxyde de plutonium pour les sondes
spatiales qui vont très loin de la terre
est très loin du soleil c'est le libyan
ska finir là par exemple mais comme
voyageurs on avait comme galileo en
avait parce qu'elles ne peuvent pas se
servir de panneaux solaires elles sont
trop loin du soleil d'accord c'est pour
ça qu'il emporta terre dont c'est le
test il ya des grands panneaux solaires
peut-être suffi il ya peut-être du
dioxyde de plutonium je ne le sais pas
prétendre ensuite qui a une ogive
nucléaire dessus voilà ça devient
carrément gros c'est un vision non mais
d'accord enfin vous en parlait comme
d'une hypothèse page 106 de votre
bouquin à partir de la page 107 c'est
une certitude évidement si elle une
vision oui d'accord balle donc je peux
rien dire sur les reds il ya du
plutonium dedans ah oui je le dis c'est
pas la même chose c'est pas une ogive
moi je vis dans le jeu de tête du
dioxyde de plus vous avez vu une ogive
moi je pense que comme il ya sept
américains qui ont été récemment sur
millau et d'endives des fois il y aurait
eu du mal quand même et ils ont caché la
bombe dans un sirop coincé à l'air
encore une fois c'est possible mais tout
ça est très improbable donc on rajoute
de l'improbable à l'improbable et ça
donnerait combien n'existe pas 6-7 2/7
de troubles a
précisé mireille un ciel de plus de 3 le
problème c'est que ça tombe à l'endroit
du temps de monsieur brecht n'est finale
et pas s'amuser à lancer et à satellite
comme ça pour le plaisir c'est à
l'époque tous les gestes de l'urss
s'était de pour châtier le grand ennemi
est donc venue la guerre des et de la
guerre des étoiles plein de vols
d'accueillir les retours bon alors
maintenant c'est clair les scientifiques
scientifique parce que jésuites pas
exactement quand vous c'est possible
c'est hallucinant vous êtes l'un des
francos quoi
morival envoie la photo
alain gillot-pétré le pen fait
penser aux téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent et qui doit pas comprendre
grand chose à susi je suis contre elle
bon moi je dirai tout seul pour toulouse
j'essaierai de dire qu'ils abhorrent
j'essaierai de dire tout d'abord 1 999
après jésus-christ donc après sa
naissance il y avait eu l'an 2000
n'existait pas une invention de
passionnés des mouches rabat ou du genre
tu joues the rescue des chaussures je
suis vous avez vous
allez sourire vous allez vous allez
sourire qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 990
s'est passé à lyon qu'on annonçait la
fin du monde n'est pas vrai si nous
sommes à finir monsieur gravats ne soyez
pas réagir les sages étudier sa hausse
hier à des amériques et villa cieux on
annonçait la fin du monde qui
commencerait par un déluge et
l'archevêque de lyon voyons que sa pose
et du trouble dans les esprits et monte
en chaire dans la cathédrale de lyon et
à dix après avoir interrogé le très haut
la date de la fin du monde est reporté à
une date ultérieure
ça ne méritait pas me
rendre aussi donc
ok parce que ça a été inventé la fin là
l'accord du miel maladie s'était inventé
au 19e siècle par les romantiques
créneau d'achat mes amis artistes ont
étudié ça il n'y a jamais eu de perdre
en 2000 d'abord pour une simple raison
de l'ambiance de la mairie qu'elle ait
pas besoin des couples et dont il est
trés qu'ils n'avaient aucune il savait
uniquement qu'ils étaient sous le règne
de tels roi ils savaient même pas ni le
jour ni l'heure où il était et ça c'est
faux et ça c'est de la vision des ddd
des gens du 19e sur la partition pour ce
que les prix des gens du moyen âge qui
était plus cultivé et plus éclairés que
les gens d'aujourd'hui car le moyen-âge
est aujourd'hui monsieur tu le paies
très de vous c'est n'y avait pas content
si tu passes mais je suis parce que j'ai
le feu à l'intérieur et moi ce soir avec
la vision une humeur le feu
evans a tenu avant ma part tout moment
d'une maladie
inconnue comme mon organe monsieur effet
valorisé
la comece planète de ferran sortie d'un
collège
ce bond faire
échouer je m'attendais
mais attention
dans les années qui viennent tous ici
nous aurons des problèmes d'argent oui
nous aurons laissez moi finir je vous en
prie nous avons des problèmes personnels
de santé nous aurons des problèmes avec
le patron nous avons des problèmes de
boulot en un moment pas au même moment
peut-être mais de toute façon on
n'annonce rien qui ne soit prédictible
l'astrologie est en fait la possibilité
pour certaines personnes d'annoncer aux
autres ce qui ne peut pas ne pas leur
arrivée est le cas ici et c'était l'idée
que je voulais c'est l'idée que je
voulais vous dire madame et que si ça
fait du bien certaines personnes et bien
si c'est une psychothérapie je suis
relativement pour parce que c'est
effectivement les croyances à faire du
berlaymont maintenant d'un point de vue
scientifique
n'existe voyez vous madame vous une
grande différence qui entre vous et nous
pas monsieur rabanne c'est que vous vous
défendez votre big stack mais nous le
défendons la vérité mais nous c'est
gratuit c'est au lycée
ça elle est végétarienne
en plus c'est le jack pot pour finir
avec la prévision d'elisabeth tessier à
propos de cassini même si c'est possible
et encore plus fausse que d'accord écrit
donc vous ce qu'on peut dire pour
conclure c'est quand même le but de le
ben oui mais à taux et j'ai fait une
erreur d'une semaine dans la date car
assez près de la terre le 18 ou 6e 11
j'ai dit vous avez écrit le 11 vous avez
écrit le 11 bon merci à tous mais pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus